[Music]
on this sunday night resisting russia
battles rage throughout ukraine i
believe that people will fight till the
last drop of blood
no matter we will die we will win but we
will win the mass exodus from the
country as the two sides agree to talk
turning up the pressure on vladimir
putin this is a watershed moment
tightening sanctions and unprecedented
measures aimed at ending the invasion
also tonight separated by war it can
happen with you
in every home in europe families forced
to part and facing an uncertain future
and live from new york a powerful
tribute to ukraine
global national reporting tonight
sophie louie
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
there are significant developments out
of ukraine and russia tonight after
another day of intense fighting both
sides have agreed to their first talks
since the invasion began the ukrainian
government says the talks will happen
monday morning at the ukraine belarus
border even so vladimir putin has put
his nuclear forces on high alert blaming
what he calls aggressive statements made
by nato powers and his forces are
pushing forward around ukraine's capital
new satellite images show a long convoy
of russian forces and vehicles rolling
toward kiev ukraine's foreign minister
vowing ukraine will keep up its
resistance
the goal of russia is to destroy
ukraine as a state is to destroy
ukrainians
as a nation
but
we will not fall
we will not stop or get tired
this is people's war
today canada promised an additional 25
million dollars worth of non-lethal
military protective equipment to ukraine
though canada and its nato allies have
bolstered forces in eastern europe
defense minister anita anand says they
won't be sent into battle in ukraine
a combat mission is not on the table at
this time nor is it on the table for our
allies including the united states
and all of this while the assault on
ukraine continues and the exodus to
neighboring countries grows europe
bureau chief crystal gemensing is in
poland near the ukrainian border crystal
you visited a number of crossing points
what did you see today
sophie the medica crossing is where
cameraman braden and i crossed just six
days ago you can cross on foot or go by
vehicle
now there is a steady stream of people
coming across with suitcases or hauling
bags
some are crying others
are just sitting there with a blank
stare on their face which honestly is a
little more haunting because it makes
you wonder what they've seen most people
use them across ukraine the marks of war
are everywhere in its second largest
city russian forces have been relentless
in their attempts to overtake harkief
the days-long battles punishing
my colleague
on sunday russia's president moved his
war closer to the edge ordering a
nuclear alert directive
putting russia's nuclear arsenal in an
increased state of readiness is a
dramatic escalation that raises concerns
the crisis already a full on assault
could next lead to nuclear warfare
whether by design or mistake
it's a video
with the
bombing
of my house this man left keith before
the bombing started there now he says he
has no choice but to move his
11-year-old daughter to poland
i choose her safety and that's it and
this is very difficult for me it's hard
to see a clear path to peace but that
remains the stated wish of ukraine's
president vladimir zelinski has agreed
to meet with russia in belarus after
talks with its pro-russian leader but
ukraine will concede nothing
zolensky says he agreed to the meeting
to show his people he's dedicated to
ending the war
this is all my life here it's all what i
have with me
polish officials now say 200 000
ukrainians have crossed over its border
nearly every face either streaked with
tears are almost blank expressionless a
sign of the shock so many are living
people arrive continuously on foot in
cars
and on buses there is a lot of work
being done to organize donations you see
piles of clothes but also food
transportation but it is a bit of a
chaotic situation people are wandering
around not quite sure where to go asking
for help
be a group of ten people my children and
my sister children
in the sea of people arriving one stood
out walking towards ukraine after
escorting four grandchildren to safety
this woman is heading home yesterday
i have my work there
and
i have my house
my home
that poll to go home to be in ukraine is
just so strong but for the majority of
people
it's just not safe
sophie
our europe bureau chief crystal gomez in
poland tonight crystal thank you
ukrainian forces are continuing to hold
their capital from the russians but
there is word tonight the city is
surrounded associated press reporter joe
fetterman has been in kiev since the
fighting began and joins us now joe
thanks for joining us once again it's uh
it seems very quiet and key of right at
this moment but things seem to change uh
at any moment the situation can change
there what's going on now
yes i'm in the heart of kiev central uh
central part of the city near the main
square and it is not only quiet it is
eerily quiet i mean it is so quiet that
a neighboring building
has wind chimes that i can hear tingling
and jingling when there's a breeze here
in the heart of a normally a very busy
street
so nobody's out on the streets right now
we're under curfew and anybody who goes
out is considered a suspect and risks
being shot so
that said the quiet does not always last
we're in a lull we've seen many of these
lulls and they usually they may last an
hour or two but they're frequently
interrupted by air raid sirens last
night there was gunfire behind us so the
heavy fighting has not reached the heart
of kiev but it's certainly on the
outskirts of town and the fears are that
it's getting closer and closer and in
fact what we're hearing from the mayor
of kiev he's told the associated press
that the city is encircled uh what is
that doing to the the mood of people in
kiev the the threat of russians getting
closer and the concern about supply
shortages in the days to come if the
situation doesn't change
yeah the mayor gave us a mixed message
on one hand spirits remain high i think
people are encouraged by the leader the
president zelinski
standing up for his people remaining
defiant i think they're encouraged by
signs that the ukrainian military is
performing well and inflicting heavy
damage on the invading russian forces
but at the same time he says the city is
surrounded he says it's too dangerous
for people to leave right now and he's
worried he says things are hanging on
for the time being but he's worried
about food supplies he's worried about
medicine and he's worried about the city
eventually being strangled by the
russian forces
now joe talks are scheduled for tomorrow
between the two sides what's the
reaction from people in cube to that
news is it optimism or is it skepticism
i would say it is cautious optimism at
best people have been through a lot the
there's a lot of mistrust toward the
russians and uh president putin has been
very unpredictable throughout this whole
thing so there are a lot of question
marks surrounding uh these talks uh
starting with what are russia's motives
are they serious about these talks or is
this something just uh just to buy time
uh we don't even know when these talks
are going to begin we don't know what
the agenda is going to be is it going to
be just a short-term cease-fire or is it
more substantial talks talking about the
issues that led us to this point who's
going to represent the sides are they
going to be senior decision makers or
just low-level diplomats so there's a
lot of uncertainty a lot of question
marks here that said anytime you get the
two sides together any time that they're
talking to each other that gives you at
least something to latch onto
for hoping to resolve this crisis
we'll see if anything comes of those
talks all right thanks for joining us
once again associated press reporter joe
fetterman in kiev well the head of the
european commission says ukraine is
quote one of us and we want them in the
european union the eu adding more
sanctions today closing its airspace to
russian planes and taking the
unprecedented step of financing weapons
for ukraine redmond shannon reports
an ovation for ukraine's ambassador at
the reichstag after germany's historic
decision to send weapons to ukraine
reversing a post-second world war
pacifist policy the creek is a
catastrophe
chancellor olaf schultz also adding new
funding for germany's military and a
similarly historic move from the heart
of power in europe too
for the first time ever the european
union will finance the purchase and
delivery of weapons and other equipment
to a country that is under attack
this is a watershed moment after
financial sanctions with canada and
others the eu adding more measures
targeting russia our airspace will be
closed to every russian plane
and that includes the private jets of
oligarchs too russian airline aeroflot
forced to cancel all flights to european
destinations i mean it's just a total
sea change that happened over a 48-hour
period it's remarkable bill browder has
campaigned for a decade for sanctions
against vladimir putin and his closest
allies
the oligarchs hold their money and so we
have to go after the top russian
oligarchs other new measures include eu
sanctions against russia's ally the
lukashenko regime in belarus a wider ban
on russia's central bank from accessing
its foreign reserves and kicking many
russian banks out of the swift
international bank payment system
full details on that are still to be
decided but some russian banks will be
exempt likely to allow europe to buy
russian oil and gas so there are
questions to be asked here and ways to
extend the reach of these sanctions in
the days to come analyst josh lipsky
believes the block on foreign reserves
could cause a shortage of cash or even a
run on russian banks plus inflation plus
food prices going up within russia plus
supply chain shortages now so all of
those things together put enormous
pressure on the russian economy
in the vatican prayers for peace rather
than sanctions pope francis calling on
more governments to open up humanitarian
corridors for refugees sanctions against
russia are not just coming from world
governments oil giant bp says it's
selling off its stake in a russian oil
company and fifa the international
soccer body says russia's national teams
cannot play using their flag or anthem
that is if any country agrees to play
against them sophie
redmond shannon in london redmond thank
you the sanctions canada and its allies
have imposed on russia have yet to deter
the attacks on ukraine so will canada
take things a step further and ban the
importation of one of russia's biggest
exports oil and gas mercedes stevenson
put that question to foreign affairs
minister melanie jolie on this weekend's
edition of the west block
is canada prepared to ban the
importation of russian oil and gas to
canada because we do import some now are
you ready to cut that off and say no we
already have oil and gas in canada we're
going to find a way to use that
we're ready to do many things mercedes
going back to your last question it is
important for us to play a role
including in our ports including on in
our airspace including when it comes to
our imports but when we will do so we'll
do that at the same time as our allies
because first and foremost that's the
best way to have a lot of impact at the
same time second we don't want to create
a loot poll canada won't be the loophole
in this entire strategy so that's why
i've been in contact with my colleagues
from the g7 i spoke to secretary blinken
on friday with my colleague from germany
um
on thursday and that's why also i'm
having this conversation and this
meeting with the g7
it is very very important that people
watching us right now know that the best
way to be
really imposing a lot of pressure on
president putin right now is by by being
united and we are
it doesn't seem like the sanctions have
absol in any way slowed down or stopped
vladimir putin though so what else do
you need to consider
well i've mentioned you many many things
uh and like i just said everything is on
the table i think we can be extremely
proud of uh ukrainians right now which
are fighting for their lives and that uh
are in a very dire situation
ahead how the russian invasion is
prompting renewed calls to build the
controversial keystone xl pipeline
crowds gathered across canada today
including in downtown toronto for a mega
march to support ukraine and to condemn
russia's invasion of that country the
crowd gathering at yonge and dundas
deputy prime minister christian freeland
in attendance in the sea of protesters
well with the russian invasion there are
renewed calls for the u.s to restart
construction of the keystone xl pipeline
speaking on abc's this week white house
press secretary jen saki gave no
indication the u.s would reverse that
decision anytime soon
i would say that the congressman's
recommendations there the keystone
pipeline was not processing oil through
the system that does not solve any
problems that's a misdiagnosis or maybe
a
misdiagnosis of what needs to happen i
would also note that on oil leases what
this actually justifies in president
biden's view is the fact that we need to
reduce our dependence on foreign oil on
oil in general and lead to and we need
to look at other ways of process of
having energy in our country and others
tc energy pulled the plug on the
keystone xl pipeline after u.s president
joe biden revoked its permit in 2021
the u.s is sending millions of dollars
in military and humanitarian aid to help
ukraine and its people but president
biden maintains he will not send
american troops into this war jennifer
johnson reports
while u.s soldiers remain outside
ukraine ready to defend nato allies
more american military equipment is
coming in the u.s has pledged another
400 million dollars in military and
humanitarian aid to help ukraine fight
for its survival we are grateful for
everything that is there already and
that is about to come and we need more
because we are defending the our country
against a very strong enemy u.s
president joe biden has asked congress
for an additional 6 billion dollars for
ukraine most for its military the white
house is dismissing russian president
vladimir putin's threat that he has put
his nuclear forces on alert as the west
continues to aid ukraine this is really
a pattern that we've seen from president
putin through the course of this
conflict which is
manufacturing threats that don't exist
in order to justify further aggression
president biden is re-emphasizing that
american troops cannot enter this war
without creating further historic
escalation you have two options
start a third world war
go to war with russia physically
or two
make sure that
a country that acts so contrary to
international law
ends up paying a price for having done
it along with severe economic sanctions
from the u.s canada and the european
union big business is beginning to act
google is now blocking russia from
monetizing state media on its platforms
including apps and youtube and a handful
of airlines will no longer fly into
russia delta suspending its partnership
with russia's aeroflot
while others are protesting in a
different way dumping russian vodka from
bars and restaurants like in canada evil
pie is going to be offering five dollar
f putin
shots of ukrainian vodka and all
proceeds are going to go to support
humanitarian efforts in ukraine more and
more businesses and individuals aiming
to hit russia where it hurts in protests
of this unprovoked war
jennifer johnson global news washington
global national will be back in a moment
[Applause]
russian riot police are cracking down as
anti-war protests spread across the
country more than 2 thousand people were
arrested today at demonstrations held in
48 russian cities in saint petersburg
riot police carried away protesters
standing arm-in-arm in the frigid
temperatures and in moscow demonstrators
hit the streets with anti-war signs
before many of them were detained and
taken into custody
after serving as a launch pad for
russia's assault on ukraine belarus is
holding a referendum on amendments to
its constitution that would allow
nuclear weapons on its soil belarusian
president alexander lukashenko cast his
ballot today in a vote that's almost
certain to pass under his autocratic
regime the country has been a
nuclear-free zone since 1994.
next snl breaks with tradition in
tribute to ukraine
[Music]
one of the sad realities of war is that
innocents get caught in the crossfire
for ukraine it is more complicated
because all men between the ages of 18
and 60 are prevented from leaving so
that they can join the fight that's led
to tough choices that no family wants to
make mike trolley reports
the layers to this reunion between
mother and son are as complex as they
are cruel to hug his mother again this
ukrainian boy had to say goodbye to his
father who was forced to stay back to
fight and have faith that a total
stranger would deliver he and his sister
across the border safely
that's the stranger the boy said
pointing to the woman in yellow
and they cried
[Music]
one mother for the joy of seeing her
kids again the other for what she may
still lose the two adult children she
left behind in ukraine
there is too much agony on ukraine's
border to process it's tragedy on
constant repeat little children still
clutching the trappings of the happy
normal lives they lived only days ago
now confronted with miles to walk along
a muddy border and an uncertain future
my father is military
so he's in kiev he's defended kiev if
they haven't already paid a price for
their freedom they know it could still
come down the road
my message will be very true that it can
happen with you
in every home in europe
because nobody knows
what
he
what putin wants
and where he will finish it's that
sentiment that's drawn oleg hurt to this
same border crossing a ukrainian who now
lives in germany he didn't have to
return to his homeland but his mother's
sister and extended family are still
there the russians he says must go
but oh the sacrifice he's making
schwager
i've left my wife and three children
behind he says but i'm going because i
can't live with it
that's war an endless series of awful
choices where no one ever wins
least of all the children who are seeing
their families torn apart
for reasons few can explain
microlight global news
and that is global national for this
sunday night i'm sophie louis we leave
you tonight with a tribute to the people
of ukraine
this is the ukrainian chorus dumka of
new york performing on saturday night
live with the song a prayer for ukraine
thanks for watching and have a good
night
[Music]